all right well uh first i just want to
thank everybody for being here you know
we we appreciate the media's assistance
uh
and the power you can bring to some of
these old cases
um
you know we come to you today with a
kind of some mixed emotions we had uh we
had some great progress in this case
um
important update uh on a case that's 41
years old so um just kind of a testament
to the the dedication of some of these
detectives that are in the room today uh
i want to thank john williams for coming
out um really appreciate you being here
started the case in 1980
and is still invested so thank you very
much for being here
uh so i just want to give you a short
background on october 5th
1980 at about 9 pm
the the body of a young deceased female
was found in the city of henderson
in the area of royal grande boulevard
and lake mead parkway
the female was initially located by
passing motorists in the desert area
and all attempts to identify this female
over many many years were unsuccessful
since that time this female has only
been known as jane arroyo grande
doe
at the time the clark county coroner's
office
ruled jane's death a homicide
the initial detective in this case john
williams
investigated the homicide from 1980
through his retirement in 2006.
i was humbled to find out just recently
that detective williams and his wife
paid for jane's burial costs initially
just thank you for that for your
compassion sir
uh and he continues to visit her
gravesite each year on the date of her
death
after his retirement john has remained
invested in the case uh even to the
point at in 2015
he went with the new lead detective joe
ebert to the national center for missing
and exploited children to present the
case
since 2015 detective ebert has remained
committed to finding jane's true
identity in an effort to bring closure
to her family and to pursue her killer
the amount of work joe has put in
is just astonishing in this regard
i'm proud to say today that detective
williams and ebert's efforts
have finally paid off
we have positively identified jane
arroyo grande doe as tammy karine
terrell
she was born on the 4th of july
1963.
tammy was 17 years old at the time she
was murdered
we were able to identify tammy with the
use of investigative genetic genealogy
just the background on investigative
genetic genealogy it involves the use of
dna testing and databases to determine
relationships between individuals and
identify possible relatives of
unidentified victims
detectives then contact these potential
relatives
an attempt to identify family members
are missing
or if they can provide additional leads
on possible other family members that we
can contact
through this process this lengthy
process i would say
we located two of tammy's sisters
who were able to confirm her identity
when they supplied us with dna
tammy sisters i will tell you were
tremendously grateful
to finally know
what happened to their sister 41 years
ago
you know now we're only halfway there
now the pursuit of tammy's killer
or killers begins
we are seeking the public's help to
bring tammy's killers to justice
and i wanted to provide just some basic
information that tammy was last seen
at a restaurant
in roswell new mexico
after the roswell state fair
on september 28
1980
she was seen with a white female and
white male adult
and if you have any information
related to who these individuals might
be or if you've seen her in the area or
in any progression from new mexico
through arizona to nevada during that
time frame
we ask that you contact us
at the henderson police department at
four 702-267-4700 five zero
or you can also contact us at crime
stoppers at
joe put in 702-385-5555 effort but we
had a ton of partners in this uh in this
endeavor and i would just
be hesitant to say if i didn't recognize
some of them
first the volunteers
of the henderson police department cold
case unit who come in and volunteer
their time to assist us in investigating
these cold cases we really appreciate
your effort
the fbi
barbara ray venter with firebird
forensics
the national center for missing and
exploited children
the clark county coroner's office
and terry muir when the unsolved
mysteries team
i will open it up for one or two
questions there may be some that i can
answer but this is still an active
investigation
so there's some i may not be able to to
address
she was not a henderson resident
we do have cause of death cause death is
determined to be a homicide
blindfold trauma was the initial
causation
technologies in dna how how big is that
for law enforcement
you know with the unidentified folks it
is uh you know any murder investigation
it begins with with knowing who the
victim are and knowing who they're
associated to and so it's a major hurdle
um if you don't know who that person is
i mean obviously uh tammy was not known
for 41 years
so as in anything with law enforcement
we try to stay up with the times right
we try to stay up with the new
technology
dna has obviously made leaps and bounds
from when at this time you know dna
wasn't there they didn't have a great
knowledge of the dna
they were smart enough to still take
samples of things for future you know
future hope of of progression but we
continue to see
advancements and so as those
advancements come out
we try to implement them and learn about
them and then include them into our
investigations which for some of these
cold cases is amazing
just to be able to identify an
individual from you know 41 years ago is
is unbelievable
so that was on september 28 1980
she was dropped off at the roswell fair
state fair she was later seen that night
around 10 pm
at a restaurant in roswell and that's
when she was seen with a white
male and a white female adult
and that's the last information of where
she was seen that we have
she was found
october 5th
1980 so roughly a week later
you have a roughly a week time frame
where she was found from
either traveled in some mechanism from
from new mexico uh to here
i can't get into that information with
you that's one thing i cannot answer
so she was from new mexico she was
living in new mexico yes that was
correct
in roswell
all right well anything all right
website and i just wanted to talk a bit
about the influence that this case has
you know really just how it feels to
have
you know some closure we have a photo of
her right here
yeah you know it's amazing we uh
you know just we we've we've been
looking into cold cases obviously we
never let these things rest um we've
made some advancements you know our our
volunteers have been crucial in keeping
a lot of these cases alive the
detectives investments
i mean john williams is here and i know
he just got out of the hospital recently
i mean it just shows his investment uh
we've also made uh put some mechanisms
in place where we have a a team
developed now that looks at these cases
they go back and look at them
holistically so they look at you know
new technologies new leads
it's a cross-section of detectives crime
scene analysts lab personnel uh to where
we can we look at leads that may not
have been exhausted
um that you know new technologies may
address um and so that we implement that
and and it's kind of a team environment
to roundtable those things now so
uh you know it's it's it's rewarding i
mean obviously these
you know john's been on this case for 41
years i mean he's wanted to know who
this who tammy was for 41 years you know
he goes and visits her gravesite so you
know i'm sure there's
there's some satisfaction in that um but
that's only half the story you know we
still need to find her killers and bring
him to justice and that's going to be
the important next step so we thank
everybody for being here we really do um
you know we the power media and helping
us you know develop leads and and and
seek out these people is always
important to us so we appreciate your
partnership uh we wish everybody the
good rest of the day thank you